yes we have a red heat alert warning now
from the met office which is suffice to
say the highest possible alert warning
that the met office can issue and that's
from monday and tuesday and it's because
there's now thought to be around an 80
percent chance that the uk's temperature
record will be broken on monday but more
likely on tuesday that's currently set
at 38.7 degrees centigrade that was set
in cambridge in 2019
and there's also around a 50 chance that
temperatures on monday or tuesday next
week could hit 40 degrees here in the uk
which is unheard of i mean it quite
literally is unheard of it would be
completely record-breaking it's a
clearly very dangerous level of
temperature that's why the red warning
is in place essentially what that means
from the met office is that there is not
just likelihood but a probability of
dangerous weather which could lead to
risks to life first and foremost also
disruption to travel train services
particularly likely to be affected the
med office is also warning that because
more people tend to go to the coasts and
coastal areas during heat waves there's
a likelier
incidence of water related
incidents and harms there's pressure on
the health service already because of
the increasing instances of heat related
health problems heat stroke heat
exhaustion and things like that there's
possible disruption through power
supplies
as i say trains roads you name it so the
message from the met office really is to
take firm precautions stay at home if
you can don't travel this really is a
serious level of heatwave so much so
that the met office has really escalated
this to the highest possible level of a
red alert warning for monday and tuesday
so it's very much a case of taking
precautions and bracing for really quite
record-breaking extraordinary heat on
the way next week